the most memorable Oscars moment hands
down is one that I was a part of
Unforgettable Oscar moments Barbra
Streisand winning for funny girl my
family stood up cheered then we listened
to a lot of Barbra Streisand records
Olivia Coleman winning for the favors I
remember watching it and crying along
with her it's genuinely quite stressful
when Little Miss Sunshine got to go to
the Oscars and I remember going for the
first time couldn't believe I was
sitting in that theater I think I
probably didn't say a word to anyone the
whole night you like in Phoenix speech
at mentioning about his borrow River
Phoenix I got tears actually it was when
I was not named the winner of an Academy
Award but my son Chester who was young
came to with us that night he came over
and gave me a big hug and he said I'm
sorry you lost the Oscar Dad it was a
wonderful heartfelt moment I'm urging
anyone in the first Oscar went for us to
Iran went to ascar farhadi for
separation and I never forget that night
the first year the Oscars had the
animated film category and as we work in
animation we were super proud about that
and beauty and beast got nominated for
best picture it was really cool to see
an animated movie up there being
represented
would be when Louise Fletcher won the
Academy Award
and signed her acceptance speech I want
to say thank you for teaching me
to have a dream I'll never forget that
moment I remember seeing it and she
spoke my language that was truly special
it seems an obvious choice but was the
midnight win that was a part of
moonlight that was my first film that I
was a part of we had to come up on stage
and take an award from La La Land it was
like the Twilight Zone Moonlight best
picture
I was just so happy though that was a
mistake because Moonlight is a film that
has touched so many people's hearts
there's nothing more extraordinarily
exciting than hearing your husband's
name called as a winner of the Academy
Award that's pretty incredible or I
could say the Streaker because you know
that was pretty fun too
foreign
[Music]